simon cupertino which is where the
headquarters of apple is located and
here they have the apple visitor center
which is one of the coolest apple stores
ever they've got all kinds of cool stuff
and they even have some exclusive merch
so let's go in check it out i love the
new pride apple watch
also have a really cool augmented
reality experience so this is a replica
of apple park and they hand you an ipad
and then you get a chance to actually
see inside you can also adjust the time
so you can see what it looks like from
morning until night now it's time to go
upstairs
there it is apple park right across the
street now we're cutting through the
roof here we're gonna go back down on
this side and that's gonna take us to
the cafe
drinks snack snacks this is the cutest
thing i've ever seen they just made me a
little latte that has my name on it this
is peak latte art right here